[musique]
Mon souhait était de retourner à Gaza avec mon mari et ma famille
À R
[musique]
protection
Son père, Joe, a décidé de venir réaliser l'impossible
Pour que nous puissions sortir, il a dit que ce serait peut-être mieux et j'espère que ce sera mieux
Je veux dire, il a l'espoir pour son fils qu'il ira bien et qu'il se rétablira.
Il voulait
Dieu
[musique]
Dieu soit loué, mais demain il n'y a pas d'électricité, ils ne sont pas là
Il n’y a ni électricité ni eau et nous vivons dans des conditions difficiles
C'est difficile, les bombardements et leur état psychologique sont dévastateurs
Et créativement, ils sont actuellement dans les écoles, je veux dire
Ces gens sont sans abri dans les écoles parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
Ils vont à la maison parce que ce ne sont que des expulsions
[musique]
Nous les pleurerons en morceaux, en morceaux, en morceaux
Nous voyons des nouvelles de parties de corps et de martyrs
Et blessés, nous pleurons
Et nous devenons nerveux, ce qui signifie que nous craignons aussi pour nos familles.
Ça leur arrive, je veux dire, un
je ne peux pas imaginer
La situation: j'ai parlé à ma famille, à ma famille et à mon mari
Dire que c'est la guerre la plus difficile que la bande de Gaza ait jamais connu
Pas d'électricité ni d'eau, même de communications et de réseaux
Internet est coupé. J'appelle mon mari avec une carte de téléphone portable.
Il n'a rien
Internet est coupé et rien n'est nécessaire
[musique]
Une chose, je suis une mère qui a des enfants et qui ne peut pas sortir
Je suis venu avec lui et j'ai dit que nous travaillerions pendant deux jours
Le docteur en immunologie vient le voir et fait quelque chose pour lui
Analyse et c'est pour Yamen
Alors il s'est assis et nous avons dit que nous resterions deux jours
Et nous allons
C'est ici
La guerre, puis notre peuple à Gaza, chacun d'entre eux
L'appartement et sa mère font confiance à mon oncle, me dit-elle
Honnêtement, si on meurt, prends soin de Yamen
Je lui ai dit, par Dieu, à mes yeux, c'est elle pour qui elle pleure
Attention, ils ont donné de bonnes nouvelles de la cueillette, pas de la cueillette
Pas de nourriture, pas de boisson, pas d'eau, pas besoin de partir
D'appartement en appartement à cause de la guerre et la communication était coupée et tout
[musique]
Mon mari a dit, Willie, je veux venir vers toi
Je viendrai voir le garçon et nous nous asseoirons avec toi, ne m'appelle pas
Je serai là, si Dieu le veut, pendant deux heures et je viendrai
Et puis, je ne l'ai pas vu à ce moment-là.
[musique]
jour